pleased to have here on the rich eisen
show a pro football hall of famer uh and
one of the best in the business at
calling the games on fox he's called
many super bowls he's actually won super
bowls three of them uh and uh he also
was kind enough to send me an
influencers box of his new eight beer
which is great but bad for the moment
because i'm hammered doing this
interview right now with troy aikman how
are you i'm feeling great i'm doing
great congrats on the eight thank you
beer man yeah thank you we're excited
yeah i mean
it's really good it's really good two
years in the making uh
never thought i'd be making my own beer
but uh met my now partners through a
mutual friend and off we went and wanted
to do a light beer locale low carb beer
and
and what's different about eight is
relative to any other light beer on the
market is that we have no adjuncts and
no fillers no corn no rice no syrup no
added sugars and
uh it's an all malt light beer and and
yet we're 90 calories and 2.6 carbs and
i don't feel that we sacrificed any
flavor and for a light beer
you know that's saying something so i i
refer to it as a better for you beer so
you can feel good
uh while you drink it and it's available
we're all uh beers it's available in uh
just exclusive to texas okay right now
it's currently in bars and restaurants
and then the spring will be in the
stores where you can buy a six-pack
12-pack take it home
uh i hope we're having a conversation at
some point about going beyond texas that
that means that things are going along
pretty well well i mean i have had it it
is very good and i'm not really i'm more
of a red wine drinker yeah that's when
charles woodson hopefully is going to
bring some of his stuff later on very
well i am really going to be hammered by
the end of the show
um so let's let's talk a little bit of
football here um you were the winning
quarterback of the last super bowl here
in los angeles california here we go
again yeah um and uh you practiced at
ucla just like the bengals yeah right
sure what was that like foreign it was
awesome uh because as much as you talk
about how this game's just like any
other game it's not it's just simply not
and you know it you know it as soon as
you win the nfc championship game or the
afc championship game
and for me
i was in my fourth year and to be able
to practice in familiar surroundings at
ucla there on the practice field a lot
of the support staff
that volunteered with the cowboys that
week were people that were there at ucla
with me
uh was fantastic and then we played at
the rose bowl
which is where i played my college game
so i feel like it gave me an advantage
from the standpoint of just
not getting too emotional about the game
and too wrapped up in it to where i was
just comfortable with what was going on
and and that's a big deal i think in a
game like this especially for people
handling the ball the quarterbacks
especially and i've always
liked the super bowl because i always
like to see how those guys handle the
emotion of it but i think all of that
kind of helped me in my preparation
leading up to that game well i mean uh
we had michael here the other day of
course you did yeah we did we had
michael here the other day and um
he he was talking about his uh practice
uh and your practice at ucla he said on
a tuesday
um you practice and it was the greatest
practice you guys had ever had um and
and and he said this is what he when
they that was when they knew that he
this was going to happen to the bills
that hey that's exactly what he said
did you have a similar sensation
you might have verbalized it differently
yeah it would definitely verbalize it
differently i probably was not uh
feeling quite as confident but uh
we did have a great week we had a great
week of practice not just one day it was
a it was a great week um
and
yeah you just don't know i mean you you
literally don't know so i think go you
know to circle back to this game
that
people say hey do the bengals have a
chance well yeah they have a chance i
think any team when you get to the super
bowl has a chance because even if on
paper you look at it and you think i
don't know can the bengals block up
these guys you know what about this what
about that
anything can happen and you've seen it
i've seen it in a super bowl that you
just don't know the unexpected usually
does occur and it's anybody's guess what
might happen well you had uh
uh burrow in the bengals on a on a
thursday night
um just
chatting with him
and getting under the hood did you get a
sense of the it factor that everybody
keeps talking about 100
100 i i i watched him studied him a
little bit coming out of college liked
him uh but you know my assessment of him
would be what anyone's assessment is hey
guy makes good throws he handles
pressure pretty well you know i mean
when you watch film
it's not hard to see who can play and
who can't play but i really think the
the differentiator between quarterbacks
there's guys who get
you know when you take a guy in the
first round it's a flip of a coin as to
whether or not that guy's going to go on
and
and become the guy that you hoped that
he would when you drafted him and
there's a lot of factors that go into
that beyond the players control coaching
and of course good players and
all of that but what the player does
control or what he at least possesses
i think is the intangibles it makes a
difference i really do can you find that
when you just sit in a room with a guy
can you do you know when you sit in a
room with joe burrow before he's ever
taken an nfl snap that he has that it
factor i don't know i've asked i've
asked personnel guys that when i talk to
these guys you can usually tell right
you know they've already got a resume
so i'm not the one who's drafting them
but with with burrow i know when we
talked with them and you see it now in
his interviews
he he's got an edge that you know this
guy's a he's a competitor he's a killer
uh as far as how he competes
and i like everything about him and it's
obvious that he galvanizes that team and
they love playing for them and those
qualities i think are paramount if
you're going to be a championship
quarterback and what do you think is
going through stafford's head troy
aikman right now thursday before the big
game he's finally finally how good is
that the questions about well is it
detroit or is it him or is it a
combination of both and now
he could he he he was owen three in his
playoffs for his entire career he's
three you know just this playoffs alone
what do you think is going through his
temples well um
i i i know we talked to him week three i
believe it was they were getting ready
to host the buccaneers and i asked him
hey how's it been for you with the rams
and he said you know
uh and he loved being with the lions he
wanted to turn that program around you
know he loved his time there i know i
wish they had had more success but he
put in his time he absolutely did and he
said you know this is this was week
three of this year he said this is what
i always envisioned the nfl being
and it was such a great line and you
think of all the players who great
players who have been
rel
relevated to you know basically being on
these teams that aren't that good and
and then for him to come to the rams and
now he's in the super bowl i can only
imagine
what he's thinking now if he thought
that this is what i always imagined the
nfl being week three how's he feeling
now but enormous pressure on him as we
know and on this team to get to where
they are
and yet here they are so i've known
matthew a long time uh he he grew up
where i now live in in dallas
and uh won a state title there with the
high school but for him to meet all
expectations that just doesn't happen
very often so uh i'm proud of him i'm
proud of the proud of the rams and what
they've been able to do and
maybe they can finish it off he's played
mistake-free football pretty much i know
that well and the other part of that
rich is i will say that
what you know there were those things
hey you hadn't won a playoff game like
you alluded to a minute ago he hasn't
beaten his record against teams with 500
records all all of that stuff and and it
was out there and if you retire that way
that's the narrative that's what they're
saying about you
and yet now
he's
he's doing what i was able to do he's
got good players around him right
and and when you have good players
around you and you have good coaching
you tend to beat a lot of those 500
teams and you tend to win a lot of
playoff games and he's been able to do
that and i've i've been thrilled to see
it happen hall of famer troy aikman here
on the rich eisen show um so
i i'm gonna ask the question about the
cowboys and it it's an infused way of
asking it just okay i'm just coming
straight through the front door with you
but i think it's an appropriate way to
ask is what's missing what is missing
with the camera so that is that is the
million-dollar question that i get asked
and and i honestly don't know um there
was a time where i thought maybe i did
know um but
i think when you take a year like this
for instance and they had a great year
and they are as talented as any team in
football and as someone who gets a
chance to see a lot of these teams
because of the thursday night schedule
and the sunday package
that i'd put their roster up against
anyone's and
they they played great they didn't play
as well down the stretch but
and then you go into the postseason and
you just don't play your best football
but this isn't the first time that
that's happened they've been the number
one seed in other years and failed to
get out of the first round
and so what is keeping the it's it's
hard to imagine in a league when you see
teams like cincinnati
and
like jacksonville a few years ago and
others that you can point to and yet for
the cowboys for 25 years they haven't
even made it to an nfc championship game
it's hard to believe because when you
look at their regular season record over
the last 10 or 15 years you know they
they're one of the best in the league as
far as their winning percentage so
i don't know i i really don't know but i
do know this heartbreaking for that
organization and for jerry jones to have
the team that they had and pretty
healthy when they went into the
postseason and not to get out of the
first round um
really defeating and it makes for a long
off-season makes for another long season
in 22
because this is a team fairly or
unfairly they're going to be judged on
what they do in the postseason well i
mean again we have dak coming in here in
about an hour and you know clearly he
had a remarkable season based on of the
way his previous season ended but the
way the the game ended it's just it just
seems like can you can you can you point
the finger at the coaching staff do you
think here or is it something that's
unfair to do because circumstances yeah
i think it's unfair i think that the as
far as the last play goes i mean there's
a lot of opinions on that of course
and i know that mike mccarthy has
defended the decision
and i don't necessarily disagree with
the call
but when you run that play you 100
percent have to get off another play
into the end zone and when that doesn't
happen for whatever reason if it was the
officiating if it was the dac went too
far or when he ran
it doesn't matter
in that sense then it was a bad call and
and i think you have to just own up to
that if you don't get a shot into the
end zone when you're already in a
position
to take a shot into the end zone but uh
yeah it's a it's it's uh it's tough it's
really tough and i but i don't blame the
coaching i think that's the easy out i
think that's what people do
but no i think overall i think they're a
very well coached team
and uh just didn't happen for him well i
guess and the good thing is is that
everybody's back on the coaching staff
right that helen moore didn't get a gig
and dan quinn was shopping around and
then came back
and then i i don't you know
there is you might have missed it while
you were making your beer and launching
your lager available in texas and
hopefully everywhere else soon um that
there was a there you go right there
right next to you um that um that there
was a an article on
dallascowboys.com of jerry flat out
talking about dan quinn coming back and
he's head coaching material and sean
payton was on the staff before and
everybody
knew at the time that he could be a head
coach and jason garrett and he's talking
about dan quinn being head coaching
material and well what about mike
mccarthy and his answer as well mike
knows that someday he won't be the
dallas cowboys
and it's just lord does
no
he
guess he does you know like what's up
with that you know i mean is that that
sounds like i don't understand that one
do you yeah i um
what we do know is this is that
jerry is really smart
you know i mean he's a really smart guy
and so i i i don't you know and at times
as we know sometimes he'll shoot from
the hip but i think that
you know in those comments i think he
had time to really reflect and and know
what he wanted to convey and how he
wanted to say it so
for that not to
for there not to be more support there
there there had to be a reason behind
that is that to
you know warm up the seat a little bit
motivate i i don't know but
a little unconventional i definitely is
there's no question about all that so um
what do you think a few minutes left
here with troy aikman again eight beer
is uh available in texas and is there's
eightbeer.com for more information for
you to see how you can get it um so
what do you make troy aikman of tom
brady retiring and then six days later
on his podcast saying never say never oh
i i i think i would have answered it the
same way i don't make anything of it i
mean i doubt that tom's gonna come back
uh but we have seen him miss an entire
offseason before when he was in new
england and then they went on and i
think they won the super bowl that year
um so it's not outside the realm for him
to maybe come back but i i don't think
that's his intentions but i understand
that what do you mean you would say you
would have said the same thing well i
just think that for
if somebody's asked hey do you think
you'll ever come back um
i i do believe in the theory that
yeah i think there's always a chance you
might do something you know so why
totally close the door on and even
though in all likelihood you're you're
done i i
i would be surprised if tom came back
and played but i think for him to answer
it that way i i don't think should have
you know sounded the alarms maybe the
way that it did i i reached out to him
i've really enjoyed him being with the
with the bucks because with them being
in the nfc i got a chance to see him a
lot got a chance to talk to him a lot
and got to know him a lot better than i
did and selfishly i hate that he retired
and i probably speak for a lot of
football fans out there because he's
playing so great but it is it is such a
commitment i mean forget what he's
missed out on with the family because
you do miss out on quite a bit
but putting your body through that at 44
years old i don't think people
understand what he had to do during the
week in order to get ready to play the
next game it's not easy it was hard for
me and i was 34. now it was a different
game guys got hit a little bit
differently but still at 44
that's that's hard i mean really hard
but i was hoping selfishly he'd play
another year i knew 45 is what he
mentioned that he wanted to play to and
the great year that he had this year i
just figured tom's a guy who when he
sets goals he achieves them i really
thought he would come back and play
another year but uh we all knew it was
going to end at some point but man what
a you can't even put in perspective
what his career has been um
there needs to be something named after
him i i don't know what that is i don't
know what it looks like but there needs
to be something significant within the
nfl that reflects
on what he contributed to our game
because i really don't think
and and i really don't think anyone
represented our game better or
represented themselves better than tom
brady and i've told him that and i've
said it to a lot of people and i really
believe that i mean guy won three out of
his first four right and that's what
we're already saying if boro wins here
then he's on pace and we're going to be
looking at every kid who comes out can
he catch tom this whole pace that thing
about pace is you know a little crazy in
week two they'll say this person's on
pace to to you know have you know 4 000
yards receiving i i you know pace is a
little bit overrated but
yeah i think that when people start
trying to put into perspective somebody
at a young age achieving what
i i don't think i i know records are
made to be broken and all that and we
don't think there was going to be
another michael jordan and maybe there
still hasn't been right you know and all
that i i can't imagine
anyone ever doing what tom brady has
done because
as much as what we're just i just
mentioned about on pace and we heard it
last year with mahomes holmes beats
brady then he's one step closer you
still have to potentially most likely
win four after turning 37 and the most
remarkable that you say how do you put
it in perspective the one way to put it
close enough in perspective of brady is
that you and i and all of us are shocked
and disappointed of 44 year old retired
yeah because
we're like oh my gosh i mean the last
touchdown pass he threw
was over jaylen ramsey yeah in an nfc
divisional game with a game on the line
and he needed to throw it and yes that's
a hall of famer he's throwing to in
evans but it was perfect and he led the
league and everything is amazing and
everything and and he
you know what he proved in tampa is
yes he had great coaching and i'm a huge
bill belichick fan and how can you not
be and the greatest coach ever and you
know he had a great support group around
him in new england to flourish
but when he goes to tampa and did what
he did it it really put an exclamation
mark on
just exactly if anyone doubted his his
contributions or could have another
quarterback done what he did in new
england
the answer is no i mean he elevates
players around him he's competitive
beyond anything you can imagine
uh there's not a guy this is the
remarkable thing especially he's gotten
older
i don't think there's a guy who's ever
shared a locker room with him that
doesn't feel like they have a personal
relationship with him
and i can tell you that's hard it's hard
to do but tom makes it a priority for
him and he's a great guy he's a great
father he's a great quarterback uh he
just exudes excellence and i'm really
proud of him yeah one way to get to tell
if somebody played with him is they
referred him as tommy you know yeah like
most of us refer to him as tom well his
dad does because his dad he's tom brady
he's the tom brady
his dad's so damn proud uh all right
troy aikman so uh collins risks calling
the super bowl you called your first
super bowls together right we did yeah
in jacksonville we called new england
philadelphia that was that was joe's
first joe's first yeah our third year
together right and uh then we've got fox
has two of the next three super bowls
after this one okay so all right very
good yeah how many of them are going to
call uh
well
i should know here in another week or
two
will we know if eight beer is available
on amazon prime that's one way to sell
this thing that is one way to sell it
that would that would be kind of fun
wouldn't it if it was available on
amazon
out there yeah i'll just i like the way
you're go you're thinking right now i'm
i'm all about the branding
trust me i mean can you because i saw
that
honestly
for anybody
hold on for a second so uh when i first
got this i'm like what are the blue
squares for and i'm like oh wait a
minute that's the holes in the eight yes
i'm like oh so i i explained that to
something because i'm always afraid do i
mention it do i tell them kind of and
when i sometimes i say you know the the
logo is really a colon but on a white
can it then forms the number eight and
they're like well yeah of course you
know like i'm an idiot like what else
does it you know and then those times i
say they're like
well you can tell i really tried your
beer and liked it because i just flat
out said it just so you know that people
who haven't tried your beer or really
aren't into it they'll go higher edges
like yeah that's a good beer yeah you
know i mean they'll go they'll go up
there that's their higher octaves
yeah yeah i like it so that's the way to
tell i just flat out said i really like
your beer man awesome and i'm not that
much of a beer drinker but i really
really like i'm proud of it
on twitter and instagram i follow you
should as well great to see you thank
you great to see you enjoy your time in
l.a back here in l.a hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here